welcome to this video playing fruits car
and fruits calm and French someone
requested more French game so i will i
will get some in or at least 11 game for
the moment the winner i'm going to play
this funny sideline with 97 b6 I have
some experience with that mostly in
blitz chess okay let's play that pretty
quickly hahaha I'm taking the Queen now
what what guy supreme of business was
that I was thinking uh I was just
putting it in a pre move yeah because
well what else Queens it's reia or queen
d1 know what not yeah everybody sees
that the Queen hangs Queenie for Bishop
86 pre-move night f1 I mean neither
three yeah right obviously didn't have
it on the right out and I can just take
the Queen well this is a non-game yeah
you know I would still uploaded this is
really funny I put out this beauty mean
in my case it was a pre move but this
was not a pre move yeah it was simply
hmm some are not not seeing had the
Queen eggs that's funny yeah normally
this line goes something like that Queen
back and then Bishop to a six and you
try to trade those those bishops and
them then play on the structure but you
have some issues with this this pony
well he cannot analyze this this is
funny okay i hope you enjoyed this
thanks for watching